before we get started today link has a
trigger warning if you have a deeply
rooted fear of not flying but crashing
in a plane
you should probably skip to like the 20
minute mark in this podcast we don't
know how long we're gonna be if you're
still talking about it 20 minutes you
just threw them right into okay
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits i'm rhett and
Link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are asking the question has
touring changed us has it changed how
has it changed to change to us maybe
that's an odd question maybe that's uh
well Italy it's gonna lead to a lot of
self-reflection and I I think also I
don't know from time to time would like
to verbally process our creative process
and I cuz spoiler alert it has in a lot
of ways yeah so we'll be talking about
how we're seeing touring in the future
how we're thinking about our music how
the way that we interact with music as
individuals influences the music that we
give to you all stuff about that it's
gonna be awesome yeah you're gonna love
it yeah I'm planning I'm planting seeds
in your brain and telling you how much
you're gonna like that's good a lot of
this has to do with making the decision
to do the concert that we did at the
North Carolina State Fair which was a
bonafide concert ended up being two
hours we can get into all that bonus but
but I've been saving I haven't had an
opportunity to tell you my near-death
experience which was flying to it shut
it can I just say that you know if
you've been listening to your biscuits
for a while you know that a lot of times
we have these stories that we hold back
from each other and then we tell each
other for the first time in your
presence yeah on ear biscuits and this
one probably more than anyone you've
ever held back has been the most
frustrating to me
because the little bits that I've heard
are that you that you had this was an
intense death-defying experience that
may have changed you how has my flight
to Raleigh changed me and you've kept it
from me because it had four weeks so
that you could wait to tell it on an air
biscuit so hopefully all the steam
hasn't been let out because yeah well I
don't want to build up the story too
much but I do want to share it because I
mean he had me shook once again I'm
shook everywhere I go something happens
and I'm shook shaky-shaky wrong lyric
it's just parlance of our times you know
I don't think of our times maybe of a
time gone by shook yeah I mean the way
that you used it I think you made it
sound like it was from the fifties well
here's the thing so you flew home a day
or two before me because it was around
your birthday and then I was trying to
minimize my time away from my family
your family was all gonna what's going
on with you so I flew in days later so
you were not on this plane and I mean at
it just so happened that the hurricane
that was coming across the Florida
Panhandle was predicted to cross over
the raleigh-durham area where the
airport the raleigh-durham International
rdu what is the UN Rd you stand for
raleigh-durham International no I think
it's really I think I think you're right
there's the D U in Durham you don't just
go Rd because that sounds like Hardee's
but why is it not rd i raleigh-durham
International I hug no it sounds too
stiff anyway raleigh-durham you um you
start to get a little shook pre-shoot I
got a little pre shook because I'm like
am I gonna make it to the show I mean
we're supposed to fly in we're supposed
to be flying in the North Carolina the
same time the hurricane is flying across
North Carolina matter of fact there's a
hockey team they're called the
Hurricanes yep they were they've been
very successful and I was thinking it
time I was nervous because we were
playing this show and you were coming in
the day before and then there was the
chance that you might not be able to
make it because of the coincidence of
the hurricane and there was like
contingency plans potentially going to
other cities and right you're like
you're well I was contemplating how I
would do the show by myself
mm-hmm because I did not want to
disappoint the dorten Arena goers right
you know all the mythical beasts who
showed up but then I was like I don't we
could talk later what that would have
been like let's just say I'm glad I
didn't have to do it
so we're flying in I mean it's like a
five-hour flight and then and then you
know in the last I don't know
hour-and-a-half
we start they start the pilot starts
giving warnings like we're probably
gonna experience some rough air you know
the storm coming coming across the state
it sounded very calm about it sounded
very calm but he said you know what I
think we've been it it looks like we're
gonna be able to land and we've been
cleared for landing well it wasn't like
we're about to land it's like it looks
like we'll be able to land when that
time comes like you know 20 minutes from
now whatever 30 don't worry now story
then when we start making our descent
but it seems like we'll be able to do it
but it was kind of like that it was like
it seemed like we'll be able I don't
want to make any empty promises right
okay so you all die it was a little
disconcerting and I'm sitting alone
there's no one in the seat beside me
that's convenient
hmm well that one to hold that was good
until it everybody grab so we we we do
start making the descent well as we
start coming in to raleigh-durham it's
like you know it goes from being clear
you see all these clouds on my gum nest
to hurricane down there you saw it from
above the clouds clouds I mean I've seen
a radar of a hurricane but you don't
really see the swirl when you're when
you're in a plane is what I'm what I'm
telling you I learn that you can't see
the swirl when you're at a plane and we
start we start the descent and there
starts to be some shakin
I was shook okay quite literally and how
how did this this initial shaking
compared to normal normal turbulence
maybe maybe a little bit more aggressive
but I never get worried yeah I never get
anxious because I have this magical
ability like if there's nothing I can do
I'm just I just check out I'm like all
right yeah well I don't I don't have any
control I meant exactly the same way I'm
super worried about getting to the
airport on time right but as soon as I
get to security there's nothing like no
way this could this plane could turn
upside down and I'm not in control so
they they they make an announcement
we're we're okay we're we're gonna be
hitting some rough a Erica you need to
buckle up stay in your seat and they
start the descent and then the Quirino
we go into the clouds and it starts
getting shaky and about that moment a
woman comes walking from the back up to
the front she was to consult with the
pilot and then a flight attendant
stewardess I was gonna call him but I'm
not gonna do that you shouldn't do that
who was buckling herself up stands up
and says no ma'am you have to go back to
your seat and the woman goes I have been
holding it at a long time I can't I have
to get in there and she goes past the
flight attendant flight attendant kind
of like exasperated shakes her head well
you gotta choose choose your sits down
to buckle up all right girl and then get
on yourself
or having your neck broke in the
bathroom and vintage ones worse we start
going into the clouds and it it really
starts shaking it was it was just
disconcerting and then we come out of
the clouds and we are in a sandwich of
between clouds we were in between two
layers of clouds it was very bizarre you
see the swirl then still didn't see the
swirl but we then we start going through
the second layer of clouds and not only
are we getting is it bumps but all of a
sudden we're experiencing swaying Oh
like that's new that I've never
experienced this on a plane so a little
bit of this I will I'm not this
a lot of ship is so if you yeah you're
turning on an axis that it's going from
your head to your butthole if you put
your hand yeah if you if you put your
hands flat where your engineers out
there who need the axis have you if you
ever seen somebody do the twist that's
what the plane was doing it was it was
the the plane was wagging its but that
feels like a problem to me I have never
felt anything like it and it was just I
mean it made the plane as huge as it was
feel small like I'm part of it enjoyable
not at that point man I mean it was it
was it was nasty and but you still
weren't worried about your life I
started to be because your toddler wife
was let me just say so your wife Oh
texts me while you're in the air I'm
currently on Billy I'm on the ground in
North Carolina I'm in Fuquay Varina this
is one of her worst fears for herself
yeah no actually I was in Raleigh cuz I
was eating yeah I went to my birthday
dinner that I heard you were underneath
the her with my 16 year old nephew who
shares my name Isaiah ret we call him
what they call him Isaiah but what does
he get it on the weekends or something
no but we shared a birthday dinner
together with I wrote in a limo with a
bunch of teens awesome smelled
incredible and I am it wasn't the
birthday celebration your of Yacht rock
from last you know your 40 morning was a
lot different like a flat tire your wife
texts me and says something about I'm
worried about link being able to land
first of all your wife text me when
she's worried to see FYI but and so and
I'm like you're a French you can text me
my friends I'm cool with I'm like you
know what you know I mean anything to
worry about
I'm currently on the ground in Raleigh
it just feels like it's raining a little
bit it's not even windy it's not gonna
be a problem
well apparently nice apparently that's
why they gave him the go-ahead to land
but I mean a toddler a few rows back
start screaming what's happening what's
happening and again yeah a toddler okay
like a two-year-old like a kid who can
barely speak is saying what's happened
that's the best kind again and again and
again and I just
it took everything in my being did not
turn around and say shut up we're
crashing just shut up about it everybody
else is just kind of like just getting
quiet what's happening now
the week before I decided to watch with
the family to reintroduce them to the
amazing television show that is lost
starting from the pilot episode which I
forgot that the entire pilot episode
matter of fact the whole first season is
just a reliving of the most cataclysmic
plane crash you could ever imagine a
plane literally splitting into because
of turbulence and I watched this the
week before so I started to feel
nauseous did you start looking around
and think am I gonna be the leader am I
gonna be Jack Shephard or John Locke
well or Sawyer I'll tell you exactly
what I thought I'm gonna be Sawyer but
listen the the plane started to beep in
weird ways like alarms started to go off
in the way that's like never heard that
before yeah and and we're still doing
this like shimmy-shake like [ __ ] alarms
yes
what is a kid saying now okay I didn't
have anybody to talk to I just I was
literally feeling nauseous like I was
like all right I'm gonna grab this where
am I gonna vomit my shoe no that sack
yeah you got a sec
and I thought to myself link make up
your mind right now you're gonna survive
no matter what happens I literally had
this conversation with myself an
interesting intent and it was weird
because again it's like I know I have no
control and I'm like I haven't been
watching those safety videos all you got
to do is jump right before hits the
ground
hey yeah like an elevator you'll survive
right right a falling elevator yeah
physics man but literally I thought to
myself okay no matter what happens just
just grit your teeth and survive no
matter what like if you you know if
you're gonna crash or whatever it's just
like just have an attitude of survival
I've never had that conversation with
myself like
it's just gearing up for it and then
there was more Swain and a huge drop
like freefall but you know oh no and we
just and we're we're in the we're in
that second layer of clouds that's when
the plane splits usually I'm like oh my
gosh please just let me see the ground
please just get to the ground we can we
can do this and then all of a sudden we
clear that's the bottom bun of the
hamburger of clouds and I see the ground
in that ground is a lot closer than I
thought it was gonna be oh yeah by that
point and that's that's that's not good
that's what you don't want and then
we're and I'm like need altitude and of
course I know the geography so I know
this is Jordan Lake and we're
approaching in like plane speed we're
rapidly approaching landing which is at
least good that we're I feel there's no
where you're gonna die no we're gonna
get a landmark for your death spot no
we're really close to the landing strip
okay but then it didn't even though we
were out of the clouds we were still
shimmying okay I mean again it wasn't
like once or twice it was unlike
anything I've ever felt in a plane if
you I mean it would be like I'm
sidewinding on ice in a car anyone
throwing up at this point
everybody was quiet except for that even
the toddler shut up you're good once we
hit that big drop that's what it took
and and so we were like going up and
down and shimmy and I'm looking at the
ground and I think I'm gonna vomit and
die and do whatever it takes to survive
and I'm convinced that the plane felt so
small and it was moving in such an
unnatural way that I was I could totally
believe that at any point it could just
be slapped on the on the surface of the
earth just like watch you know that drop
we had a few minutes back if that drop
happened right now how we would slam
into the earth mm-hmm I we should have
put a trigger warning on the front of
this video if you're like really okay
I'll do it right now we'll slap this at
the top we've done it before we'll do it
again
if you
have a if you have a deeply rooted fear
of flying well not right say before we
get started today yeah do that before we
get started today link has a trigger
warning if you have a deeply rooted fear
of not flying but crashing in a plane
you should probably skip to like the 20
minute mark in this podcast we don't
know how long we're gonna be if you're
still talking about it 20 minutes you
just threw them right into okay the no I
mean the nexus of this conversation I
think that's the most dramatic part that
we just talked about so okay we didn't
we didn't get slapped into the surface
of the earth at that point well I see
the runway and I'm like whatever you do
don't land I'm like sending sending on
like sending a message to the pilot
through my passions just just I don't
know what that means but I was scared
you're passionate I was like I was so
passionately hoping that he would not
land because it seemed impossible and
we're and then we're over the we're over
the runway and we're about to land no
yes like how far off the ground if like
I mean I don't know let's definitely
like hundreds of feet okay it's 300 feet
alright and thank goodness he pulled up
he pulls up and he doesn't try to land
and we and like people started clapping
a few people said whoa and then I heard
somebody say don't clap yet' yeah was it
the toddler no it was his voice got
lower anybody right he went all the way
through puberty and that he was right
because then we had five we had to we
had to traverse through both buns of
that hurricane's hamburger gotta go back
up through the hamburger and it was it
was it was a lot of the same stuff but
he seemed to like power through a lot
quicker and then all of a sudden we're
going to Charlotte we're gonna land in
Charlotte because they're running out of
gas and the Sun came out and it was like
it was like utopia
well this undid encumber the Sun
and then we went to Charlotte and we
landed I got on the ground and ate some
fries from Wendy's tried to settle my
stomach just fries yeah um Jenna Jenna
wasn't sitting with me but she flew with
me so she was mini seats back and then
when we got off the plane for a second
they said we're gonna take off and go
back to our to you it's cleared up but
before we didn't get off for a second I
got some fries and she was gone and then
she comes back a few minutes later she
was like I just had to tell you I just
had to get a shot of whiskey it was
traumatic yeah she seemed a lot more at
rest at that moment in me after my fries
and then we flew back to our do you I
mean it was like two hours later and it
was it did blown all over you know yeah
that always blows over that's the life
lesson you know what oh but I don't blow
over as we as we stay as we started the
ascent and they said don't clap yet' and
we're like going back through this
turbulence then the Sun comes out then
you're glad no oh then that woman came
out of the bathroom no no no I swear no
no way not you I'm so sorry I almost
forgot that's the best part and I be
true and I I looked at her in disbelief
and she she strutted down that aisle
like she was the one who was piloting
the plane you know like she had saved
the day you're not making this cool as a
cucumber he was in the commode she was a
whole town through everything well
talked you don't know if she was on the
she was she was she may have been doing
like some sort of like four point
contact stance right she's like Tom
Cruise and Mission Impossible whatever
whichever one that one was where he's
like dangling from the spider rope I
don't know if there's a seat belt on a
airplane commode there's not I've looked
for it but she she walked out with her
head held she she's like sticking her
chest out like like a proud rooster I
don't know why she so she didn't want to
seem embarrassed she didn't want to seem
embarrassed you know wasn't bleeding
look confident when you screwed up right
I always say that knows now you think
maybe she is responsible for all of us
yes I made it guys but I've flown a
couple of times since then and I gotta
be honest a little bit of turbulence
brings it all back mmm like I started to
feel nauseous when we hit just a couple
of bumps before and you know I have a
lot more empathy for Christie who has
had made a lot of progress on her fears
so I didn't try to go into the details
with her so you haven't told her the
story I told her right when we landed I
called her in Charlotte I was like we
made it it was it was it was quite a
ride I don't think I need to tell you
about quite a ride okay
but I need to tell you about it so
thanks for listening glad you live
hopefully me you listening is therapy
for me so thank you
I'm glad you lived and made it to the
concert so I didn't have to play the
show by myself that's the main reason
we're going to talk about that we're
going to talk about touring but first we
are going to let you know that this
coming this coming Friday is Black
Friday that's cuz Thursday's
Thanksgiving you know what's happening
on Black Friday a big ol sale in
mythical dot store 20 to 40% off and
it's through Black Friday through Cyber
Monday right is that correct twenty to
forty percent off everything in mythical
dust or can we do that yeah I don't know
I was told that that's what's happening
I don't know I don't know if it's smart
it could be stupid but whether it's
stupid or smart you should take
advantage of it because this is the time
to stock up on everything at mythical
dot store there's there's repla there's
clothes there's what what else do we
have
Fellman there's clothes there's mugs we
get the bugs we get you still got
keychains feel like you're at the
roundtable of dim lighting with your
good raceless I say good luck for the
hats
whatever forget we got beanies right now
we don't have beanies yet soon maybe
wait
there's lots of stuff go check it out at
mythical dodge store and you know equip
yourself to be even more mythical than
you already are
music is Magic Man music is a big part
of our lives and it's also a big part of
our brand
I mean of rhett and Link of us being we
wouldn't be where we are today without
music as an aspect of what we started to
do on YouTube well we wouldn't have
started really wouldn't have started
doing I mean the core of our comedy when
we were coming up was musical comedy you
know that and we really liked making
videos but the at first those things
really weren't coming together like we
would write funny songs or whatever but
we'd make videos for school projects but
it did event that's when those things
came together that's what gained
distraction on YouTube right but I guess
what I'm saying is like this stuff that
I know that the first thing that sort of
got views on YouTube was the pimp my
stroller which was a parody video but
the stuff that we got featured like the
videos that got featured the videos that
went viral were right those songs that
we had written songs that we had written
with never an intention to make into a
music video the unibrow song
[Music]
the Facebook's on
[Music]
I'm probably two of the best examples
songs that we wrote with a live audience
in mind the unicorn rap is what we call
one actually we didn't call it that
until we decided to make it into a video
and we just added unicorn and that
actually I would get that actually is a
little different because that was only
ever intended to be a video because it
was like for a messenger or whatever yes
true but like you think about the ones
that actually because nobody really
watched that one either but the ones
that really got traction in those early
days there were songs that were written
with a live audience in mind that then
when YouTube came along we created music
videos for them and that was sort of the
beginning of what rhett and Link comedy
was mmm-hmm
and you know in a way we are returning
to those roots I think that's one of the
things that is happening as a result of
us touring well you know I sometimes I
enjoy kind of connecting the dots in
what it is we're doing now what brought
us to this point hopefully as a listener
you will enjoy kind of tracing some of
that if you're interested in our
creative process or I don't know why
you're interested in this but I am so I
guess I'm going to talk about it but I
mean we decided I guess the operable
question that were asking is how his
touring changed us I mean it's certainly
altered and informed our career
trajectory even currently and I'm
actually very excited about where it's
going so I can unpack that a little bit
we decided I mean we decided to do the
show at North Carolina State Fair fair
and just to do a concert just because we
were we were itching to do a show we
were willing to do we were willing to
entertain their offer or their
invitation to come because we had toured
the previous fall with our tour of
mythicality which we were only willing
to entertain the possibility of doing
that because we written a book and it's
like if you write a book you're supposed
to tour in some way but we didn't want
to do a book tour so we did a stage tour
and then we had to like make a whole
stage tour
thing and then so this even having a
willingness to go on tour which is
something that people brought up for
years
for us it's something that only writing
a book pushed us over the edge to
actually do well we had always shied
away from it because one of the things
that made YouTube so attractive to us
was the fact that we could create things
and reach a large amount of people
without ever leaving a studio and being
able to go to work and then come home
and be with our families and so that's
what YouTube afforded us and then and I
do remember that we talked about this
particular thing in a whole other
podcast when we were back when we were
at some point in the process of the tour
of mythicality it's not that we have to
rehash that but I will say that having
gone through the experience of the tour
mythicality
we're not like hey we could we find
ourselves being invited to do more have
more stage appearances to like meet more
fans and to travel more places I mean
going to Australia was amazing that was
another year biscuit where we talked
about and we knew that even though the
show was based on the book and kind of
goes through some different aspects of
the book we knew well if we're gonna get
an audience together and we're gonna
perform for them we know that we're
gonna do some live music because in one
sense that's our bread and butter that's
something that we really enjoy doing and
we think we'd do it well and but we we
we had we did this exercise where we for
the tour mythicality where we said okay
well we need to perform X number of song
just like five or six songs we should at
least write a new song and they needed
this and they need a tie-in to kind of
the narrative they need to be something
that makes sense based on where we're at
in the show right but they also need to
be the kind of songs that makes sense to
perform live and that the result of that
was picking some songs that and this is
actually the case with a lot of people
like how did you choose the songs you
did for North kind of State Fair we'll
get into that but how he chose the songs
for the tour is what songs can we
confidently perform live they will sound
good and they will be the jokes will
work for a live audience and as a result
we ended up going into places like going
all the way back to a song that we wrote
over
fifteen years ago the middle school
girlfriend song hmm updated it made it
what we think is significantly funnier
than it was originally and performing it
and then writing a new song and then
anyway it was a totally different
process that really whet our appetite
for the insane let's do this
more seriously take the show to the
state fair but not take the show not
take we decided to do a special show we
decided I can't remember exactly what
this what made us decide to do to say
yes to that invitation because that's
something we normally just wouldn't say
well we did it to put I mean I remember
because after having done the tour which
was incredible in a lot of ways I mean
we talked about it multiple times but
like being able to be in the room with
mythical beasts is very special it kind
of we were open it goes beyond what
we've been able to experience you know
just digitally with people online and
we're in it was a hometown gig so we
were open to so well maybe we should go
I'd be coolest like we saw him are all
there it's like a lot of memories
associated with that but the reason we
committed to doing it is because we said
if we do this if we commit to an all
music show at the North Carolina State
Fair but why did we even think at all
music show because I know what you're
about to say but what with the idea to
just do a concert and not do that do not
do another tour mythicality stop because
we think because we want to do something
that is even further reaching and
broader more broadly appealing that was
my reason and we didn't want it we're
not gonna keep touring with the tour
mythicality anymore yeah do something
that is what we feel is the best parts
of the show and we've got more songs
where that one came from where those
came from
and we can write some new ones and it's
more expected I think people I mean at
least a segment of the fans they were
expecting okay if I'm gonna come to a
show I mean you're gonna perform songs
isn't that a concert
well it wasn't yeah well I think there's
a lot of people always thought that if
you cut a lot of people who've become
mythical beasts in recent years think
that when we say when you hear rhett and
Link live they think they're going to
see like good mythical morning live they
think that they're going to see like us
on stage eating weird
getting people on stage and you know but
that's because those people got into the
game a little bit late and don't realize
that well the thing that we're
passionate about the thing that we love
to do and we think the thing that is the
most entertaining thing that we can do
in a in a theater or in a Dorton arena
is music and I think the other thing
well and then here's the thing we found
I'll skip to after the show you know
once we started meeting fans after the
show a lot of people had tour
mythicality shirts on all they had been
to that show and then they had been to
this concert so I we would always ask
him which one did you prefer and if and
if they had a preference where I'd say
maybe the McSteamy the people we asked
did have a preference the the remaining
one said I love both of them it's just
like they're just you know encouraging
fans but if they had an opinion it was I
liked the concert better I like what I
just saw better and I think it that felt
good because it aligned with our own
experience which was man it was easier
to do and it was kind of it was more of
it was in that wheelhouse of were
performing songs easier to do I find
that an interesting you think that was
easier to do it wasn't easier for me it
was definitely easier for me so I guess
for me it was like there was no pressure
beforehand for me I can't understand why
there's more pressure on you in like
having to play you carry the rhythm on
your guitar to play the guitar for all
these songs that you know and having to
relearn them you know I or transpose
some of them to guitar that never were
intended weren't written for a guitar to
be have ahora like I have a horrible
memory when it like we had monologues
for the tour mythicality
and like I have I'm that's really hard
for me but for some reason in my brain
like lyrics and melodies and all that
that's very easy for me of course I'm
also not playing a guitar and singing
and have to relearn that but like I
don't forget lyrics that much well I
think so I think ultimately I've had it
easy I would say
ultimately a music show is way easier
once I actually get what lock in what
I'm doing but I had not in fact again it
goes back to the reason we did it we did
it so we would have to force ourselves
to learn how to turn these songs into
acoustic songs that we could perform be
able to sing for almost two hours and so
I had a lot of questions about whether
or not I was going to get through that
and not forget things and forget and be
able to play the guitar parts and all
that I screwed up a number of times most
people probably didn't notice I did but
so I think ultimately it will be easy
for as long as it's been since we've
played those songs or having never
played many of this maybe half of the
songs we had never played live and then
a third of them had never been played on
a guitar ever I'll give it to me did a
great job well as always I was all just
a track I was just paying miming the
guitar the whole time oh you didn't know
that was just a track I'm just really
good at looking like I'm playing exactly
what you're hearing
all the screw-ups are built-in you know
it's just it's a big show things a
facade if you let me in on those secrets
then I won't spoil them for everybody
okay
so I was encouraged that people were
like this is what I love this is what I
want and plus the banter in between
songs is very much like those the
unscripted moments of good mythical
morning so it is kind of like you're
getting a good mythical morning
experience as opposed to like this
theatrical dramatic scripted sculpted
experience that was the book on stage
kind of thing but so but you bring up
the point that I want to camp out on
which is you said you know if we made a
decision to do this concert we knew in
the most general sense it would lead to
something like every time we do
something new it stretches us it
challenges us it aligns us you know it's
like we got a hunker down and figure it
out right in this it's a new creative
endeavor and something will
come of it and I think that's what's so
exciting is having done that once and
having not you know when it was over is
like yeah we can we can do this more you
know and we all should go to London and
do this do it at VidCon London and we're
gonna do we're gonna go from there but
it's you know it's exciting when he even
if it didn't go well
it would lead to something everything
you do to Leeds is some other decision
that you have to make creatively and I
was very encouraged that like yeah that
having done it's like yeah we can do
more of it and then the fan feedback was
yes please do more of that
yeah so it there was also an alignment
there and it also forced us to write
some new songs which is something we
haven't done I mean first of all it's
such a big part of who we were and then
we stopped doing well I don't want it we
haven't stopped writing songs because
well that's true you know we did we did
an album with each season a buddy system
and I even tend to forget that because I
feel like it's kind of now there's a lot
of songwriting it's buddy system is
hidden over there like I I acted like
buddy system doesn't exist I think we
poured so much of ourselves into buddy
system I know we talk about it every
time and then so many of you haven't
seen it but get youtube premium we want
to see it poured a lot of ourselves into
it including a lot of songwriting but
it's a little bit of a you know it's a
little bit of a shame in that so few
people some few mythical beasts have
seen it but I think but what we have
gotten away from is the songwriting
process that we employ for the the live
the live live performances and to me
once what ever since YouTube started
taking off yeah cuz something happened
you know obviously this first couple of
songs were written with a live audience
in mind so if you were just to listen to
this song just listen to the lyrics you
would laugh and then once we had the
visual component added we started
writing songs knowing that they were
primarily going to be received as a
music video and so you would write a Joe
we would literally be sitting there
writing
lyrics to a song and we would say okay
well this will be the lyric and this
will be the thing that we're showing
right so it was this incredibly visual
experience where we because we thought
we were writing a song we were right in
a music video
we yeah we wrote things with a music
video in mind from the beginning and
that's a drastically different process
and that's also frankly one of the
reasons that some of the songs you may
have expected us to play in our live
show we didn't play and then others for
some people you know because okay so one
of things we did in a lot in the show is
we had an acoustic set we started with
an acoustic set including some old songs
that people recognized and some new
stuff that we had written then we
introduced some very special guests who
was rabbit lightning and we don't know
if we did that kind of as a special
thing for the North Carolina State Fair
we don't know if we're gonna keep doing
that but it really worked for that crowd
and then we brought out the songs that
we felt obligated to play I mean I'll
give you my perspective I know your
perspective is a little bit different I
think that the fans reminded me once we
talk to them like what how I should
actually think about it but we knew that
we had to do epic rap battle nerd versus
geek
epic rap battle of manliness I'm on
vacation belly button and so ding we had
a so dang dark
[Music]
that wasn't necessarily a must-play but
those songs that have the most views of
anything that we've ever done you know
the songs that if you know if you don't
know us from anything else you might
know us from those music videos you know
the most views except for you didn't
mention OCD oh she doesn't doesn't apply
so we took a different different
strategy on OCD we did play it but we'll
talk about that so yeah and we were very
self-conscious first of all we knew that
we were gonna try to do a show that
didn't cost us a lot of money so that
meant we weren't gonna have a big screen
the tour mythicality shows have a screen
behind us that's an integral part of the
show but that's a very expensive
expensive thing and it raises the cost
of us actually doing the show we were
like especially for a one-off show if
there's a way to do this show without
the visuals then we should try that and
so we were like okay well that's just
gonna be us up there rapping and if you
listen to a song like I'm on vacation
especially I'm on vacation you're like
oh this is so much about the visuals as
so many jokes are referencing what's
happening on camera if we don't have a
screen can we can we still do this
doesn't will it make sense and also
there was a point as well how many
people are there we've never heard this
song right you're right you're right I'm
always thinking about a music video I
I'm always thinking about the person who
is walking in for the first time
probably to a fault I'm always thinking
about the audience who hasn't heard us
yet thought this was the tractor pool
right and so what I'm gonna sit down cuz
they're singing about vacation so and we
also felt pretty self-conscious about
getting up there and rapping and so we
did a you know I don't want to give away
everything that we did because we'll
probably do it again when we tour but we
have a way of couching the fact that
we're performing yeah yeah
these the Wiis alternative that are
visually motivated a couple of notes
I'll say and Venkata Vineeth on in
VidCon London for that show there will
be a screen I believe so it's not that
whenever if you know don't assume that
you know if you really want to screen
I'm not gonna say they won't
screens for when we come to your town or
whatever the case may be or for VidCon
London but the other funny story you
know when we we left stage then we do
this quick change well we we had this
creative way to do to come out as rabbit
lightning to kind of make that
transition but my mom told me later that
of course I'm I'm LAN lightning hi Milan
lightning I come back out there and I'm
talking and Louis my mom's husband
technically my my stepdad but I don't
call him that cuz he married her after I
was married and had a child he's just my
mom he's just Louis okay don't worry
about it I love him I love Louis and
that's what I call him okay he's not my
stepdad you could call him daddy for
anything is cool just call him daddy
papa
that would be grand okay say anyway my
kids call him Papa so it's cool he leans
over to mom cuz cuz we said we got some
friends who were coming out here we're
gonna give him some time they're trying
to make it in the business he didn't
know it was me that's why he's not my
stepdad you should take that as a
compliment yeah I'm very convincing red
my mom spent the like the next five
minutes trying to convince that's link
that's like what doesn't sound like him
it's an act he's playing a character
he's good got me and you know he has
that catchphrase good good good good
that's what he says do you push ups
you've been doing you know when you push
up yeah papa good good I don't know that
was it I didn't know that was you now
good now one of the things that that I
did after certainly writing some songs
that didn't have a visual
in mind for the beginning from the
beginning hey I feel like I'm always
thinking about that like the chance that
we get to perform for an audience who
isn't completely on our side from the
beginning right yeah so when we tour and
we sell tickets to a show we know that
the vast majority of people there are
gonna be pulling for us they're gonna be
fans they're gonna know the lyrics to
the songs and that's just a that's just
an incredibly fun love fest as Garth
Brooks would say in the video that we
just watched before this and it's just a
lot of fun but it's a there's a
different dynamic when let's say we're
going to and we haven't we're not doing
this yet I'm going to like a comedy
festival and it's just a bunch of people
who came to be entertained and you have
to win them over like a traditional
comedian again it's it I'm always
thinking about that crowd especially
when I'm writing something new yeah yeah
that's great cuz I mean you're it's not
like you're gonna lose people who are
just gonna love us by making something
that is the funniest thing we can make
and I think that's why I was always I'm
always been a little self-conscious
about getting up there and doing the
raps because you don't understand this
has like over 30 million views on the
internet like people really care about
this right it's not just a couple of
dads up here rapping you know so I write
and that's what my that's a personal
problem because a lot of fans said that
was her favorite part of the show but
one of the things that I did after that
State Fair show I actually don't even
remember the the moment that I made this
decision but it was when we decided we
were gonna do VidCon London and I was
like okay here we go we're gonna do some
more which means we've got a few months
to write some more songs pressures on to
write some more original songs yeah and
now I have played the piano in ignorance
for years meaning that I can sit down at
a piano and I can do some things that
may fool a layperson into thinking that
I know how to play the piano I don't
actually know how to play the piano
but if you play in the key of C and you
stay on the white keys and you it you
can make people think that you can play
the piano right and I have written some
of some of the some of the some of the
instrumentals for our songs have been
written on piano but it's very much like
I'm not playing I'm just kind of piecing
things together because I know what the
notes are yeah but I was like what would
it do for us if we incorporated a piano
into our act could I learn how to play
the piano in time for us to actually
write some songs on piano and perform
them at VidCon London or my response was
what if we incorporate a guy dressed
like a piano in Iraq yet we talked about
that for about 15 minutes
no I didn't so yes this is this is just
you in your own little space thinking
about this well yeah I mean in you I
also your space I first we have a piano
at the house right we have like oh yeah
you do an upright piano so what I did I
also have I sat down at the piano as I
do sometimes just to kind of mess around
and twinkle the ivories and and I've
written a couple of songs like that
swirl the buddy system sees into family
mantle family song
family man song that was written on the
piano but again if you listen to his
super very simple rhythm I sat down to
play the piano and I play for like 30
seconds and then Locke is like dad could
you not do that right now cuz this you
know it goes throughout the whole house
yeah at that moment because I was also
watching a youtube video about how to
play so that you can accompany yourself
singing because that's something I've
never done because I never thought that
I needed to perform it live I was just
like I just kind of kind of chicken
scratch
chicken Peck this piano enough to then
translate it to guitar or put it in
logic on MIDI earth right right but I
don't have to actually play it and sing
it at the same time but I was like well
I'd like to learn how to play and sing
at the same time you can't be that hard
if I can already do it with guitar so of
course you go on YouTube and there's
like I learned some mind-blowing things
that I have my hands backwards not like
this not like playing like this but I
was playing the bass note that I was
doing it wrong anyway no I want to know
how you're doing it wrong cuz okay this
is interesting
well so what I was doing is and I think
this is a way that you can play the
piano is so your left hand obviously is
playing lower notes and your right hand
is playing higher notes to put it very
simply and if you're sitting in a
traditional fashion yeah if you're
sitting back or just reverse it also
turn around so you can see the piano
[Laughter]
yeah hey we can make a funny piano
tutorial play a piano
we'll make you too auditory I can't yet
forgot a couple of must have figured out
so what I had been doing when I sat down
to write something is I would play a
chord I kind of figured out pretty
quickly that you know if you just
separate in the white keys if you do
every other key and you do three of them
together you're playing a chord yeah I
knew that right
and then I would play some kind of
melody with my right hand which that is
a way that you can play piano if you are
playing a song that isn't to be sung
because you're playing the melody by in
the upper keys you're like playing the
elevator version of Coplay right but if
you want to play
so that you can accompany yourself and
again if you know anything about piano
you're like this idiot doesn't know what
he's talking about but I'm just I am
giving you my layman's understanding of
this which come to VidCon London I'm
gonna be playing the piano and singing
so yeah take that we're also gonna
charge you for that for this part as a
tutorial like this is a paid tutorial
from someone who has not yet learned how
to play the piano but like that's that's
so you by the way like again I admire
this about you like you could become
convinced to like make a tutorial as
you're learning so it's just like
alright day two of me learning to play a
piano this is what you do yeah man well
okay so what I learned and that was a
revelation to me is that if you want to
play in a way that you can accompany
yourself while you're singing you're
playing the bass line with your left
hand and you're playing chords basically
rhythm mm-hmm in chords with your right
hand and then you're playing a melody
with your vocal and you're singing the
melody and a lot of song some of the
most popular songs ever written on piano
like let it be by the Beatles is like
when you break down the piano it's like
this is incredibly simple like it
doesn't have to be complex you don't
have to be Jim Brickman there's a
there's a shout out he's like a
professional pianist is that look him up
I used to have one of his albums what
okay yeah yes please keep going yes
let's forget that shout out I think I
got it through one of those Jim Brickman
on instagram BMG music things anyway so
this was a revelation to me and by the
time I finished this YouTube video you
were in tears I felt like I was on my
piano and my and I gone back to the
piano and then the kids have been like
that you've got to stop playing at that
point I went on Amazon and I said you
know what I feel inspired
I want to write some music on the piano
but I've got to be able to do it
whenever I want I need a keyboard
because I need to be able to put my
headphones on and play to my heart
content quitar did you mean is a board
higher so I bought a keyboard a Casio I
didn't want to get crazy you know knows
and I know I get too expensive okay does
it have the buttons for the beats it
does but I've gotten over I've yet to
activate those oh you haven't even
activated I don't play it beats I own
the keyboard at my Nana's house I put
the beats for you once I stop playing
with the Castle Grayskull I wanted a
keyboard and I put the stickers for the
notes on the on the keys
do you have you done have you done that
take all the stickers the stickers were
in my mind really here's one here's
something though this is something that
has been super exciting now I don't want
to build it up because we may get busy
the the song I am only gonna promise
that there will be one song on keyboard
oh gosh that's gonna be hard to justify
bringing a keyboard okay there's gonna
be two songs on keyboard can't I play
too
yeah you can hit one you can like it the
high notes I think this is a bit there's
gonna be a bit about the key boy yeah
yeah we gotta justify bringing it you're
completely right what about drum machine
we can get into that but I'm behind a
drum machine one of the things that I
have figured out is okay so my guitar
playing is is pretty limited right I'm I
can play a very reliable rhythm
I can play bar chords up and down the
neck you know I can play all the
standard chords I play a few chords or
sevens or diminished or whatever and I
do all this mostly by ear so I don't
really know when I'm playing like a
weird chord I have to like go to an app
on my phone and know what I'm playing
I never took music theory I just kind of
know what chords I'm hitting but you
pretty quickly in my experience if
you're limited like me and you never had
a guitar lesson you pretty quickly just
kind of get to the end of what you can
do on a guitar in terms of writing a
song it's like okay I can basically play
in any key in and the standard rhythms
or whatever but I can only do a few sort
of altered chords most
just majors and minors straight stuff
maybe a seventh or something like that
but when you sit down at the piano and
you just does it spread for you you
combine a few things and you're like oh
well sometimes I'm hitting the bass note
of the chord that I'm playing sometimes
I'm hitting a different chord from the
bass note that I'm playing and what the
cool thing that has happened is you
begin to hear like a genre like an era
of music coming out of the the piano so
like you you know I'm playing like I
don't even control him remember what the
chords were but like I actually miss hit
hitting a G and a G at the same time and
the chord was a little bit too high and
then I kind of like corrected it but
just going from that step up to the G it
sounded like an 80s like pop song and
all of a sudden you just start finding
that these it the world of music that
can be explored on the piano it just
suddenly hit me and I was like why did I
discover this at 41 do you think that
because it makes me think like we got a
piano in our house and I invested in
piano lessons for all three kids and you
know we've we found a good piano
instructor who I listen in on what she's
telling the kids and it's like an
inspirational it's like it it's like a
college music appreciation course she's
amazing also teaching them guitar and I
you know it's again a credit to you I
think this is this is a difference
between the two of us I was making fun
of like the confidence that you would
start you do a tutorial before you know
how to do something I was really making
fun of the fact that like you'll you'll
leap in and say I'm buying it I'm doing
what you do for me it's like well I
didn't I never learned the piano but I
want to give my kids that it's funny
that that's been my my application
because I I did have enough
understanding it's like if you can learn
piano and understand music in that way
it translates I just felt like it
translate so much more in terms of like
okay then you can move to guitar even
drums or whatever because of
what you're describing that you're
discovering as a middle-aged man I am
curious if our kids are if they're
connecting those dots or if it's
something that like is within you like
all of our kids and your kids - they
play for a while
but it's funny pretty they've done
pretty well you know because is I my
kids are very much like me and my wife
in a lot of ways but the things that I
see in them I'm like okay so both of
them took guitar locked up guitar shop
or took piano they took it for a while
and then they kind of just lost interest
right but when Shepherds since and they
both what are still they still both want
to play from time to time but both of
them maybe Shepherd a little bit more
than Locke took a very different
approach which is the same approach that
I always took like when I learned the
guitar I I yeah I've got the books and
like learned how to play like some Eagle
songs or how to do like some you know
Lynyrd Skynyrd riff or something
something like that but the technicality
of getting it exactly the way that the
record sounded yeah I lost interest so
quickly yeah I would get like an idea of
what they did and then very quickly turn
it into something original right I was
much more interested in writing songs
and I always been that way and I see I
think Shepherd will sit down to the
piano and we want him to be supposed to
play what's in the book what the
instructors told him to play but he's
making something up and that's great
that really is great I think for me it
was you really need both in a perfect
world you know the training and then the
inspiration to create your own stuff but
yeah I you know if we go back to the wax
paper dogs days it was like neither one
of us complain we were both lead singers
in our garage band in high school right
so it was and then you were the one that
made the decision this double lead
singer thing ain't gonna work
we're I think for me it's like learning
to play guitar or do anything it's like
if I feel like I can't invest enough to
do it perfectly like to invest deeply
and it'd be a lifelong commitment I
would just rather not do it it's just
that's the subconscious approach that I
have this like like
do this but I can give it to my kids you
know it's very interesting it's just a
totally different it's a way that we're
very different yeah I just find it
fascinating that without any particular
point well and I I mean I I think one of
the reasons I started playing guitar
when the white paper dogs wasn't just
because it was a little cheesy to have
two lead singers and we weren't in sync
or anything like that was that well if I
didn't start playing a guitar we were
just gonna play the songs that Minnie
wrote right what or covers right right
if we wanted to actually create you had
to create find get the instrument to
enabled the creation yeah we needed
fresh ripoffs of the Eagles and then
that was when we started writing songs
that were in no way shape or form good
but we're sort of the building blocks of
like learning how to play music together
which that's another thing that I want
to talk about because it's something you
said so we were practicing for the
concert at the State Fair in one of the
songs that was not written on guitar and
actually so we did back when we did the
mythical show we collaborated with Dan
evading of game grumps and ninja sex
party a good friend of ours before game
grumps didn't exist he doesn't exist
he just moved to LA Stevie introduced us
and we were like we when we signed up
for the mythical show we were like we
this is a lot we have to do so much and
we got no money because we didn't ask
for enough money to make it well we got
to do music videos and so that's part of
what we do and she was like well I know
a guy who a is a good musician B is very
funny who might be able to help you guys
write all this music that you need to
write for this and so we were like yeah
we've never done that we've always
written our own stuff and there's like
this sense of pride with like not
getting any help but they were like you
know what let's let's see what happens
if we collaborate so the have you ever
song
[Music]
[Applause]
the basically the chords and in large
part the melody was written by Dan
actually I and a lot of the lyrics I
think specifically they were written by
a ninja Brian because all the music part
I don't think that I think I don't think
dan I don't know I don't know for sure
but I don't think he plays anything I
think he's like me and I think that
Brian is like you and he in any place
keys and play I mean plays all the
multi-instrumentalist okay ninja Bryant
from so he because we said we wanted to
do something that was like Hall and
Oates
I don't or do they are no I just you
know what they just came back with
because that's what happened yeah they
have such a eighties soft rock sound I
mean look at the they put out two cover
albums and they like it
Toto and stuff on it it's amazing so she
just does that they do that on instinct
so we yeah we determined we want a song
called have you ever that's like you
know things that you can relate to that
then increasingly goes to crazy things
that just like it falls apart and we let
and we may have written some jokes then
we could take and turn it to to lyrics
but it was in any wrote he wrote he came
back they came back with a demo for us
first time we had ever collaborated with
somebody musically he was over email and
we realize we never met ninja Brian not
at the time no we were like well he
lived in like England or something
he was like studying in England at the
time yeah or he was a professor I don't
know lots of weird stories gonna you
can't believe those guys anyway the song
the demo came back and it was had this
80s vocal effect on it were like damn
this sounds like Hall & Oates yeah we
didn't like the chorus so we rewrote the
melody of the chorus and worked with our
producer Mark on it okay yeah alright
that's that part of the process that I
really enjoy you know again I like to
take something in and tweak it I like to
perfect things I don't you know so
starting from nothing thin a or is like
he's a nightmare for me it's like
getting just like a plane crash but um
well but the thing give me something the
thing that you said and we were when we
were practice
and have you ever there's a moment at
the end where it kind of you just start
going nuts singing yeah now first of all
I had to translate this very like Hall &
Oates eighties rhythm that needs to be a
drum machine and a keyboard into a
guitar which it loses a little bit of
its hall and oates nish Nitin Estes yeah
when you translate it to guitar but you
made the point when you were trying to
memorize that last part and we kind of
changed the lyrics a little bit from
what happened in the video that you were
like this is a melody that I never would
have come up with naturally and so it's
difficult to lock into my brain right we
had the same experience when bin Bram we
partnered with him to write the he
produced pentatonix yeah he's a penitent
onyx producer won a Grammy who helped we
basically wrote the lyrics for a
barbershop quartet if I had another if I
had another me I don't know that you
buddy system season one song and then he
turned it into a four-part barbershop
quartet song he gave us the the the
individual tracks to learn like that
they call him the stems and it was very
challenged with so it was so difficult
for us to sync because when you when you
sit down to write a melody you are
referencing a cacophony of all the music
that you have listened to and kind of
sung along to that you've connected with
and kind of your brain is melted too and
for us if you reach into this jukebox of
our past there's gonna be this mix of
things and one of those things is gonna
be a lot of country music right oh yeah
so not just Merle Haggard not just old
country but the you know Brooks & Dunn
at the time that Brooks & Dunn was
popular in diamond Rio and Clint Black
Garth Brooks there's a lot of that
there's a lot of country it's not all
cuz that all country that's one that's
one element of it right yeah but then
you've got like R&B yeah soul even some
like getting back into from
and I assume you as well like Elvis and
Chuck Berry and that kind of thing but
the these songs are all for me
especially a lot of it is kind of coming
from this light
southern rock Lynyrd Skynyrd Allman
Brothers country
R&B but like a lot of southern music you
know what I mean
and if you just listen to it like the
melodies in the way that they kind of
come out when I doesn't naturally start
singing something they can kind of be
tied back to all those genres that
influence and it's it's that's one of
the things exciting about the piano is
that you hit it throws you into a
different place that just doesn't
naturally doesn't come for somebody
who's limited in what they can do on a
guitar like I am yeah but it leads to
situations wherever you collaborating
with somebody and they come up with a
weird melody it's very difficult like
going from that note to that note my
brain has never made that connection
before i you know i'm i would consider
music my main hobby i think that the
main things I like to watch our music
documentaries I've started just the
habit of just laying in bed and
listening to music and then I started
not just listening to music on
headphones while my wife Falls this is
already sleeper something she usually
goes asleep for me I just lay there
listening just analyze love to analyze
but then starting to watch music videos
like I got on this Chicago kick I was
telling you about this where I was like
you were telling everybody about it
yeah cuz there were there were like
three three dinners that we went to I
don't know when this is coming out so
I'm not gonna say we recently took a
trip for to shoot some GMM in another
place I don't know when this episode's
coming out in reference to windows are
coming out so I'm not gonna to give away
what it was you mean Memphis can we talk
about that I don't know who cares
we went to Memphis and went to st. Jude
we're talking about it it was awesome
there's
videos about it I can't keep this stuff
straight anymore I went back to my whole
weight to go back to my hotel room and
just listen to music by myself and have
my own quiet space then I started
watching Chicago but Audient the next
meal what I'm getting at is like the
breakfast after the night like we would
get together in the morning we're
getting ready to like shoot the next
video we're all kind of like in the
hotel lobby eating something and you
would start talking about what you
experienced in the in the in the
documentary and I would kind of look
around and I was like who in this group
is actually listening listening to the
link right now and my impression was no
one did you know that Chicago the band
what I mean the first lead singer he
passed away and it's in a tragic
situation I don't want to go into but
then the second Leasing was Peter Cetera
this amazing vocalist and then I'm
watching this weird videos on YouTube
where they're like where he's leaving
the band and it's really weird and the
songs are amazing you're my inspiration
and they brought in a third lead singer
and they like Riedl Chicago revitalized
their band over across three amazing
vocalist this is not something that
anybody can do until the next night when
I discover Genesis did it let me watch
the vh1 behind the music on Genesis
until I'll just upload it to YouTube
yeah like they're ripped on YouTube 4:3
ratio yeah I guess the point I'm making
is that you know I I just I love music I
love how it moves you when you talk
about melodies I mean I'm still I'm I'm
so obsessed with hip-hop because it it
seems to me to be changing so much
quicker than how I've experienced any
other music changing and it's it's a
puzzle to figure it out and to
appreciate it and not just write it off
and then once once you start to once you
hear someone who's amazing at it like
okay you can reduce what migos does to
again you've got I don't want to go off
on all these tangents
we should do this in another podcast and
you study the rhythms it's like okay it
blows my mind I mean if I listen to post
Malone not just because I've met him and
he says he likes us and he seems super
cool and that makes me super cool if I
listen to him he I came to a conclusion
one night just in my cans the dude is a
melodic genius and I'm not I'm not
saying that because he thinks we're that
our show is entertaining it's it but
that helps there's a certain moment
where you can just listen to music and
you're like well I I get it
and I understand how difficult it is to
invent what he what he did and you know
so and it's but hip-hop is a super
distinct - as is demonstrated by the
episode that we had him on GMM you know
yeah i did i mary had a little lamb in
his style you start realizing that you
know what he actually that he invented
something like it's it's completely
everything comes from something always
its derivative and i underst right but
that's what's intriguing i mean if i
push it into a place that's that's
original to bring it back to what really
matters us i I get a lot of joy out of
out of that I mean it gets very
frustrating I know it many times when
it's like we're trying to hey is this
song why isn't this song written it's
it's over we got it you know it's like
because you know you're it's like
painting man I'm not going to tell you
how well it's fun I'm just really glad I
think they the answer of the of the
question for me is what did what a
touring do for us is it it reconnected
us with our passion for music our
connection to music and how that's a
part of what we create it's just such a
different way to
create and I'm specific and then alive
no I specifically excited about I mean
even the songs that we wrote that those
of you who came to the NC State Fair
show heard the songs that were written
with a live audience in mind and the
songs that will be written with a live
audience in mind it's just not saying
that they won't then one day we put it
turn into a music video but it always
were leave they will always works that
way so if you write something that is
funny
with just sound you can you can bet you
better believe that adding a visual it's
only gonna make it funnier it doesn't
always work the other way though if you
start with the and you have the video
handicap in it right from the beginning
and then you try to perform that song
live if people don't have the visual
reference they may not get it so I'm
super excited about that because I think
it's the the comedy quotient of those
songs is that much higher but it's also
just we're kind of discovering that we
didn't think it was gonna be a part of
our you know greater strategy but I
think that playing music live for people
at least in moderation not crazy world
tours where we're gone for months at a
time but short stints in places is a
part of what we're gonna do creatively
in the next phase of our creative
endeavor we should come back around to
it yes i'm i think that's that's it
that's the answer to the question that's
the huge takeaway is as we as we think
about 2019 that's an aspect and it's
yeah i mean some opportunities start to
come out of the woodwork you know it's
like some really cool stuff that like I
mean we got an email two days ago that
was like it was to play at a at a at a
at a at a particular venue that's like
oh that would be exciting yeah well you
know the interesting thing is that we
that was very vague by the way I love
the vagueness of that yeah okay a
certain venue they'll be very exciting
to play it I can't say that I can't say
I am very excited because if it doesn't
happen yeah I don't want anyone besides
me to be disappointed an interesting
thing in you I could not have
told you you know because you go back
ten years we've been doing YouTube 12
years but you know you go back 10 years
and that was when we were already like
in the throes of full-time YouTube 2008
we started our business we were doing
this thing full-time we're doing a bunch
of music videos that was our bread and
butter
and at the time flight of the conchords
was kind of in there in their heyday
like you know they're special to come
out I don't remember the exact years
that they're each the two seasons on the
HBO but it's right around that same time
right it's been like 10 years yeah I
think it was 2006 though and so in terms
of like comedic musical comedic acts you
know you had tenacious d had Flight of
the Conchords you had Lonely Island of
course Weird Al I'm sure there's there's
others that were missing but the
interesting thing is is that 10 years
later I would have told you that there
were a bunch of musical comedy duo's out
there or Trejo's that are that are that
are playing music and doing what we
always thought we were gonna do back in
the day and then kind of YouTube sort of
changed our plans but you know here we
are in 2018 and Flight of the Conchords
has a new special Tenacious D just
released the new album and the YouTube
Syria youtube series that Scott Jack's
all Jack drew to draw that I watched the
first episode the other night it's
hilarious oh it is and the animation is
so crazy because he just drew these pic
it's they actually genius the way that
he did it it's like it's not it's not
animated it's just it's like a
storyboard it's like it's like watching
a storyboard but it totally works
I mean when he was here he told us a
little bit about he was like very up he
was like apologetic no but immediately
upon I love the approach but I say that
to say that you know a decade has passed
all this incredible entertainment has
been created but really when you ask
people to name musical comedy acts it's
kind of the same people we kind of got
lucky that I'm super excited just don't
can sit I honestly don't consider us in
that group I don't consider it in that
group at all
and my which my point is is our
aspiration ever since we saw flight of
the conchords in the HBO special we were
on the road doing like a college tour
and in like oh six or maybe even before
that maybe oh four and we saw that
special on HBO in the hotel room and we
both got mad because they were so much
funnier than us like just so much
funnier right and I still think that
they're a lot funnier than us and I
aspire to be that funny but what I'm
getting at is that I am at the age of 41
getting ready to learn how to play the
piano so I could so we can perform a
song in London two songs you can hit the
high keys I am super excited about what
this next phase can bring and I mean and
hopefully we will be mentioned in the
same breath with those those guys at
some point right my point is is that
they got old too and they're still doing
it yeah nobody came along to replace
them
now we're old to but-but-but where we
got we had a lot more a lot more music
to play man
a lot more music to play we got a lot
more music to play yo I'm excited about
it yeah I I'm I'm so grateful that that
we decided to do than the NC State Fair
show and then it led to hey let's do
more of this and that it's a sense of
momentum you know in it and it's not at
the expense of of anything else good
mythical morning or the other things
that we're writing yeah we found a way
to because there are other things that
we are writing lots of things that we're
working on that we can't tell you about
yet but music is one of them and those
of you who've been asking is there gonna
be more of this yes there is gonna be
more and hopefully at some point we're
gonna be coming to a place near you can
we can we end this with you're the
inspiration by Chicago
we can't can't we I know that's illegal
we can't you know what you need to do
right now right after this is over you
need to you need to play Chicago bring
it up in a different tab the inspiration
and just you just play that play right
now hell yeah that for yourself
you hate that Fellman you hate your the
Lindsay that song you you got to
approach it with an open heart man
you're the mean of vocal treatment and
then go over and listen to listen to
some band of horses and you tell me you
don't like them either you don't like
them either that's your problem
don't let fleet foxes yeah listen to
some Band of Horses and see how that
vocal treatment is like a Chicago ripoff
yeah that's why you hate both them I'm
not talking to you I'm talking oh oh
well you're I can all of a sudden you're
responding as if I'm talking to you I
know I'm looking at you
it's anyway you're the inspiration music
is the inspiration I think that song was
written to music if you listen to the
lyrics you can tell it's not but let's
just say it is that song was written to
music I mean it's a good good chance of
that do you know that there's that
average white band so I know what you
mean
well I'll illustrate there's that
average white band song I got the pieces
no not the born without lyrics you dummy
listen as a few lyrics he wrote a song
he wrote he wrote at least one song
maybe multiple songs to music whoever
wrote the song was like loved music so
much that he wrote a song to it music
sweet music music queen of my soul music
you're the queen of my soul wow that's
powerful and so alright so now we're
developing a playlist now so that you're
the inspirational song leads to some no
leads to Band of Horses with that same
vocal treatment ooh
a playlist that starts and then goes
through influences influences that would
be hard to do no we're just gonna no you
a white man
you're the queen of my soul that is
interesting playlist though you'd go
back to like you know are we still
recording like a full talk at you next
week fiddler in the Middle Ages thanks
for hanging out
before indulging in us just analyzing
our own creative yeah that was very
self-indulgent I know that won't happen
all the time sometimes you just need to
talk about yourself
[Music]